je vais sentir bientôt oh oui non
tu as qu'à demander de l'argent à papa
je m'en occupe
j'ai besoin d'argent Tyler peut-être que
si tu me laisses le voir je serai
peut-être plus généreux
[Musique]
le petit qui me reste à vivre j'aimerais
me passer avec vous je vais le faire à
une condition tu vas me payer un loyer
j'en viens pas tu es toujours aussi
belle tu es un locataire
[Musique]
ça fait des années que j'avais pas vu
cet endroit
de mauvais souvenirs je suis plus le
même personne
[Musique]
j'en ai vraiment marre qu'on s'entraîne
à moi tout le temps je vais t'emmener
quelque part il faut toujours se mettre
en garde
[Musique]
alors comme ça le grand papa bouledogue
est en ville tu crois que c'est une
bonne idée
je vais te le demander une dernière fois
sinon quoi viens pas jouer au de
héros parce que tu en es pas
[Applaudissements]
m’empêcher de le voir
[Musique]
je te le promets que jamais je laisserai
encore cette pourriture te faire du mal
rien de tout ça ne compensera ce que
j'étais ou ce que j'ai fait laisse-moi
être ton père pour une fois
arrête
reviens ici
pourquoi tu es allé en prison quelle
fois attends combien de fois tu es allé
en prison plus que j'aimerais mon
souvenir